contre le terrorisme merci la parole est
à Monsieur Philippe Monier merci
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au Premier ministre puisque le
ministre de la Défense est absent pour
cause de réunions à Washington avec les
ministres de la défense de la coalition
contre l'État islamique mais avant de la
formuler je tiens à saluer au nom de
notre groupe les républicains la mémoire
de nos trois militaires morts pour la
France en Afrique du Nord monsieur le
Premier
ministre depuis la fin de l'année 2004
nos forces sont engagées contre l'État
islamique en Irak et en Syrie nos
aviateurs et nos marins ont effectué à
ce jour plus de 13000 heur de vol et
délivré plus de 1500 munitions avec une
efficacité remarquée et reconnue par nos
alliés suite à cette attaque ignoble qui
a frappé notre ville de Nice le ministre
de la Défense a annoncé de nouveaux
bombardements or aujourd'hui le niveau
de stock de bombes en service dans nos
forces ne le permet pas cette
insuffisance concerne à la fois les
bombes d'origine américaine pour
lesquelles nous sommes dépendants des
États-Unis pour nos réapprovisionnements
et les bombes d'origine françaises dont
les commandes ont été notoirement
sous-dimensionnées ces manquements
graves de votre loi de programmation
militaire ont pour conséquence de
limiter le nombre de missions entraînant
même l'annulation de certaines d'entre
elles alors que les cibles sont
clairement identifiées annoncer le
renforcement dès cette semaine des
bombardements en Irak et en Syrie comme
votre gouvernement vient de le faire
relève donc purement et simplement de la
gesticulation telle est la vérité les
Français doivent la connaître la
représentation nationale souhaite donc
être informé des raisons pour lesquelles
nos stocks de bombes n'ont pas fait
l'objet d'une remise à niveau en temps
et en heure afin de palier à cette
insuffisance nous souhaitons également
connaître les décisions que vous allez
prendre pour renouveler nos stocks et à
quelle échéance seront livrés ces bombes
pour que nos forces aériennes puisse
mener contre nos ennemis une guerre
totale merci la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Marie Logan secrétaire d'État
chargé des relations avec le
Parlement merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Député philippeunier vous
aviez déjà noté puisque vous êtes
connaisseur des questions de défense et
ce n'est pas une surprise pour vous que
jean-iv ledriillant ne soit pas là
aujourd'hui néanmoins j'ai bien noté une
question d'une ampleur extrêmement large
que vous avez pter et le gouvernement
donc peut justement vous répondre très
précisément non monsieur le député ce
n'est pas de la gesticulation ce que
font nos soldats au Levant ils sont
présents depuis maintenant des mois des
semaines et des jours et vous le savez
la presse d'ailleurs s'en est fait
l'écho ils ont renforcé leurs actions
sur cette zone notamment en raison du
fait qu'elle est au cœur du dispositif
de daesh et comme nous avons l'intention
de combattre daesh aussi bien sur les
théâtres extérieurs que sur les théâtres
intérieurs nos armées nos soldats et nos
aviateurs sont tout à fait présents et
actifs et ils sont un des membres
éminents de la coalition internationale
et je ne comprends pas comment vous
pouvez remettre en cause l'action de ces
troupes tout particulièrement
aujourd'hui pour ce qui
oui monsieurput un peu de dignité je
crois n'est pas inutile dans nos débats
parce que le respect que l'on doit à nos
troupes mérite une autre une autre
attitude pour le reste s'agissant des
questions tout à fait précis que vous
avez posé vous ne manquerit pas dans le
cadre de la commission de la défense
notamment de poser cette question à
jean-y ledriillan parce qu'elle a une
certaine utilité je n'en doute pas merci
monsieur le ministre